it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes what's going on everybody welcome
to movie fights hoot owl nation hashtag
we're Micha hooligans at welcome to
movie fights everybody welcome owl
nation welcome to this awesome group of
fighters that is ready to throw down at
our semicircle table here and make it
happen
first up oh he's the fastest mouse in
the west from Collider heroes welcome
back
coy chondro coy I know you're still
licking your wounds over that Conor
McGregor fight me I had a counter shirt
I almost wore today but I thought I
didn't need to antagonize the internet
further I'm suffering I definitely want
to defend my boys honor and for I'm
gonna win today for the homeland thank
you for being here and that will be the
extent of our MMA talk today those are
actual fights we're doing movie fight
who would play Conor McGregor though in
a movie oh that's a great I think I
would grow that beard
yeah just fold just go for I just feel
like he speaks Sorkin but fights the
fight it's very hard but I don't like to
find he speaks Sorkin yeah I'm sore can
but he also backs it up so I I want to
say like a Guy Ritchie Charlie Hunnam
like that that sounds good too I like
that he's got the swagger he could do
the strut Charlie Hunnam greenlit she is
from geek and sundry and she's a friend
of the show you know from all over the
place welcome to the party Erica Ishi
Erica give us what was something new and
exciting what's going on oh man Wow
New York Comic Con right oh yeah I was
just there for 30 hours covering but I
was literally just backstage covering
origin which is new youtube series is
just awesome right on that bunk nice
well Erica welcome back from New York
and welcome to movie fights and OH
last but not least he is the professor
mr. Juan Harris hey hey thanks for
having me lon I got to give you some
a little bit of credit here or I don't
think I've shouted you out enough for
being such one of the founding fathers
of the owl nation it was just I was
wearing a twin peak shirt featuring an
owl yeah they're not what they see and
being a catchphrase man I had a pin with
an owl on it and I love of owls hoot
hoot was born when that that very same
day so thank you for being a just a
pillar of the owl community there's an
owl that lives on my street I never get
a look at him but I can hear him do
anything what kind it is
I don't believe like a Latino the
there's a park across the street and if
I want my dog at night I can hear the
hoot-hoot but I never seen it so this is
real my girlfriend is so obsessed with
owls that every room has multiple owls
everywhere and training for this movie
fight I'm surrounded by owls and she has
a giant two-foot al tattoo I like like
her whole Wow okay she's like she loves
else like part of this whole rise yeah
amazing I'll put a just a bow on that
but by saying lon
please capture that owl and bring it in
please fight that out yes
you know what today's fights will be
decided by myself and our friends on the
Dan cam what up Dan or are you let out
yeah
the Sun is risen on a nocturnal owl talk
alright Dan what's going on any box
office predictions for this weekend
oh wow well I was just reading it's
gonna be I think it's gonna be a very
big fight - number one between venom and
a star is born
well I think they're gonna be jostling
for that number one spot Ryan honours
man's coming out which I liked a lot and
bad times - the Ellroy house coming out
which I liked a lot and nice flips - is
coming out which I saw and somebody
mildly mildly recommended so yeah I
think's gonna be a great weekend last
weekend was a great we're gonna be
another one at the box office
thank you for giving us that shot this
is my Owls how yeah I could talk about
it forever no you're not like I asked
you that question you give us that was a
succinct powerful rundown encoding
thanks brother and she is the voice of
the people
we are always lucky to have MS Danielle
Radford you know what I'll take it I'll
take it cuz you're you're a corgi gal
[Music]
Club Corgi so for the first three rounds
Dan and I will be chiming in with our
opinions and you are the conduit of the
people don't explain to folks how that
works yes I am I am the voice of the
people so there is a pool that will be
on the youtube if you're curious as to
how that works
go ahead and click down in the
description box below the polls will go
up after the fighters have given their
they have started their arguing because
we want to make sure it's based on the
arguments not just on the pic that you
would like there are some really fun
polls and things happening over on
Twitter please feel free to join those
we encourage it but the one that counts
for this is the one on YouTube but go to
movie fights live hashtag on Twitter we
will definitely be in there looking for
any fun alternative answers any of what
how likes to call dank meme oh those
sick-ass gangrene any-any start corgis
you have lying around so we will be
checking on the hashtags of Twitter as
well heck yes
Danielle thank you so much are you guys
ready to mix it up let's do it I am
alright already
JT e is back in the boots JT e getting
well on the mend
drop that package brother
[Applause]
all right Thank You Thor let's Thank You
Thor job every morning I just say thank
you thanks to Thor fit into this it's
the question number one oh yeah this is
some hot news this week James Gunn is
taking on Suicide Squad for Warner
Brothers what one major change should
Gunn make to the Suicide Squad movies
going forward all right yeah I know a
lot of us have been thinking about this
and excited about his inclusion in the
DC EU COI start us off so in my opinion
the thing that James Gunn does so well
is he makes you invest in the characters
so as I trust him to do that without
even mentioning I'm gonna say focus on a
singular villain my problem with the
first Suicide Squad was it didn't really
have something I was focusing on had
space holes it had supernatural means it
had a lot of things that are just like
pew and I never felt like it landed on a
thing that we were fighting the cool
thing about having a series of villains
that team up to fight something is that
that's the original thing that keeps
this from being like other films that
didn't use that for its strengths so I
would have the team of Suicide Squad
having a central villain and then you
could make that the hero the thing about
that suicide a sinister script I was
bouncing around with Drew Goddard wasn't
that spider-man was kind of the villain
and that was a really cool concept so
the reason you love these characters is
because you need to identify with them
so you have these underdog villains you
have them team up and then I would have
a centralized villain maybe a Martian
Manhunter maybe a Batman
someone that maybe against and that way
you'd have a focal point James Gunn is
so good at writing that he makes you cry
over a blue guy dying after quoting Mary
Poppins he makes you invest in a CGI
Rocket Raccoon he makes you believe in
things that you don't think are possible
if anyone can make you root against
Batman against Martian Manhunter against
Superman it's James Gunn and if anyone
can make you believe a team of
roundabout knock'em of villains it is
this man but they need something to be
fighting and that is why they come
together and that is the purpose of
James gun being used in this world
because that's what he does best all
right Thank You coy let's go to Erica so
what happened with the Suicide Squad was
that they were making a movie and they
had this tone in mind and they had the
pacing in mind
and then they put out a trailer that was
very clearly modeled after James Gunn's
guardians of the galaxy you know
everybody the one with Bohemian Rhapsody
everybody saw it we were all really
excited it was gonna be awesome and then
the marketing team saw that everybody
really responded to that so they handed
the movie itself over to the trailer
house that cut the trailer and what
proceeded was the editing that was
Frankenstein's monster it was a bit of
the cut they had before it was a bit of
the trailer houses cut and they were
trying to make a film that would appeal
the people based on pretty much this
trailer by son James Gunn so what they
need to do is have James Gunn's singular
vision at the beginning and then just
carry it all the way through it's that
easy honestly because he has this tone
in mind that is really pitch perfect for
it he's had like really great with
ensemble characters and so you know you
focus on the squad and you just have him
handle it all the way through production
and I really don't foresee any problems
arising if he's just in charge of it
from beginning to end because what
really there was so many cool things
that we really loved about the film you
know everybody has something - Margot
Robbie was great or you know like I
really liked this introduction or I
literally like that introduction or that
introduction
just pick one though and and honestly
just there was so much that could be
saved by good editing Thank You Erica
long so I think when you're talking
about Suicide Squad you talk about
working in a established genre it's a
team on a mission movie we've seen a lot
it's it's a Dirty Dozen kind of movie
it's we're rounding up this crew they're
gonna have this mission they have to go
do it Santa here are the steps they're
gonna take to do it the problem with the
movie or one of the big problems at the
movie is that it's giving them a threat
that they can't possibly counter it's
giving them a supernatural threat when
they are a ground level team made up of
sort of everyday kind of people they're
they're not superheroes they're villains
but they're sort of ordinary villains
Captain Boomerang has a boomerang that
has a GPS and a camera like a boomerang
with a GoPro Harley Quinn is a lady in
clown makeup with a bat or a mallet like
Killer Croc is a man
with reptilian features like these are
not superheroes their regular kinds of
people with you know like a thing an
element that makes them freakish or
weird or different but that's not the
same so putting them up against a space
witch and and having them have to fight
that kind of a madness it doesn't make
sense and it doesn't here's the core
thing it doesn't allow them to do what
they do as characters what does Deadshot
do what's his identity when we're told
about him right away he's an amazing
marksman he can use guns to go in and do
anything that you can think of that
could be done with guns and who do we
pit him against a dancing space witch
who uses magic to destroy the city well
what good is that that's not showcasing
him doing the thing that he's designed
to do so if you gave the Suicide Squad a
ground level reasonable threat that
actually matches their abilities it
would be an instantly much more
interesting movie that would actually
make sense because it's it's balanced
its this is a fight that can
theoretically win so we're you know we
get engaged with well how are they gonna
pull this off rather than an
insurmountable phone they couldn't
possibly hope to counter because then
it's just like running around being shot
at until the end when Diablo blows
everybody up all right
fight it out everybody so my thing of
the centralized villain we've similar
ideas with this solution here but I
think as long as the villain is
centralized the supernatural can still
work I think if the villain Swamp Thing
but they're all against Swamp Thing then
everyone teaming up is the whole point I
so I think that the movie as long as you
focus on the characters and then you
have Diablo and Deadshot doing
everything they need to do then it can
still land whether or not the
supernatural as long as there's a second
I agree that one of the strengths of the
I mean DC Comics universe is that you
mix these ideas so like Superman is yost
action you know action superhero a
little bit of an alien Batman is
Detective Wonder Woman is mythology and
they face supernatural threats all the
time you know it's not new or alien to
the DC the DC EU is just we haven't seen
it necessarily done in a cohesive
fashion but we do it's there and there
are members of the team that have
supernatural abilities
well Diallo he's gone
well so none of the other members of the
team as a team but there's so many
members of the Suicide Squad in the
comics kit can be supernatural faces
supernatural okay but that man is Batman
nobody on the Suicide Squad is Batman
that's what makes bad some of them they
were even better than Batman like in in
some versions Harley u.s. commando like
he's a guy that you would send into Iraq
to go free a prisoner he's a guy he
would send into Afghanistan on a special
mission is not a god you would send
Superman what is so compelling about
this but about the team aspect and about
Gotham's universe is that you know
Batman's just a guy and he is up against
these super guy he's a genius he's a
dreamed ninja and he's the wealthiest
man in the world it's like being a guy
the point is like Deadshot is just the
guy's the guy who's a great marksman but
if you're not putting them up again
somebody's vulnerable to being shot it's
pointless you might as well be a regular
person the main villain is the point
there but I think we're both making I'm
just saying that a villain that
supernational works and I'm also I think
with the James but in a much more
interesting to put them in a scenario
where they don't have to team up and use
their individual abilities against
something that's actually realizable
that I can defeat absolutely and I
appreciate your speed roundness or
anything I I would also say that in
terms of having multiple threats as you
know for the villain that James got
handles that very well like in guardians
of the galaxy he was able to weave
multiple bad guys you know and change
some of them over to be good guys and
then it all kind of becomes a cohesive
battle for good in the end but I think
with this main characters that you're
reshaping there's no time for that you
have so many characters that need to be
reintroduced and you're setting editing
I think if James got to shoots the movie
and rights in movie he doesn't need to
edit the movie because he's already made
a James Gunn movie like the James Gunn
movie is already gonna be what comes out
because like editing is part of the
storytelling I'm just saying that they
copied someone that they're already got
but the other thing is with the editing
I don't think better editing would have
saved that first show aside you're still
stuck with this terrible dialogue you're
still stuck with this scenario that
doesn't really make sense the movie
opens with Amanda Waller saying like we
need a team that could theoretically go
fight Superman like that doesn't make
sense for the team that you've actually
assembled everything's not gonna fix all
of those prongs that you're right
fix the first one it could have made it
a whole lot better we've had someone no
change you're gonna make and you agree
that it wouldn't have fix the first one
then well why would we assume that that
one main changes what's gonna be fixing
the second one to your point this is a
sequel what comic book sequel doesn't
have at least one other villain come in
we're joining the Suicide Squad after
they're already a squad they're in
progress it almost doesn't make sense
that they wouldn't have any other photos
I invest in the National Suicide Squad
the whole point is that I want to care
about them and the first one I do so I'm
just in the Dark Knight even though he's
got to face in the Joker and Scarecrow
investing the vendors because you've met
them in other films you invest in all
these fuels that their team if you want
to start with a team you need to care
about the five or six but then we have
to my first to assess run I don't really
know them I can't describe that shot
beyond shoot stuff I can't describe than
that so one centralized villain means
that we get to meet the Suicide Squad
invested them and then they can go after
a central threat and there's that
essential we've had so many movies that
work that do a good job of establishing
this intricate I do have multiple
doesn't mean a spider spider into it's
like everybody's favorite comic book
movie you've got multiple villains in
that one as well
even guardians of the galaxy there are
multiple villains in suicides in this
yeah then in Suicide Squad there were
multiple villains and but the problem is
is that it wasn't as I said like focused
and and the idea of there being a lack
of focus and like ant-man and the wasp
it's just like how these movies were
like Martian Manhunter someone that's
stronger than them then it shows the
actual team dynamics you don't need that
you could have a villain you don't need
if it's not doing it wouldn't
necessarily like magically fix the
Mumtaz toy go ahead and roll this into
your final thoughts so my point is
twofold and that we both have a
centralized villain but also that that
centralized villain is a hero that's
something I've got to touch on much that
you want to have these people be
villains and that is the point of the
movie James Gunn writes such compelling
characters any direct so well that you'd
be compelled to follow the villains over
the hero so I'm saying the reason you
have a centralized villain is to make
that a hero we all already love and you
are invested in the villains over the
hero that makes for a much more
interesting dynamic if you had multiple
villains you wouldn't care as much about
the hero or the villains in this case
you would like James Gunn do what he
does best which is be the underdog and
root for the underdog which is with the
Suicide Squad essentially arm
thank you coy
erricka both of your arguments had to
deal with lack of focus and I don't
think that they would be changes that
would fix everything overall both
because James Gunn and in the DC EU we
have established you know multiple
multiple villains and supernatural
threats and they've been done well both
by James Gunn and in the DC EU I don't
think those are the be-all end-all for
what can fix the film good storytelling
in the end is what's gonna save the film
and I think that that lies in editing
for this franchise Thank You Erika lon
so I mean the idea I think here is that
if the Suicide Squad had a goal that we
could get our minds around that we could
understand that was clearly laid out
that's what would make this movie much
more compelling we've seen it work in
the oceans with us we've seen it work in
the Mission Impossible movies we seem to
work in films like The Dirty Dozen
anytime you have a clearly set this is
the group these are their abilities this
is the objective that this is how
they're gonna win that's like a really
clear easy fun compelling through-line
that anybody can appreciate mix up even
if you're not into comic book movies and
it would help to set this apart from the
glut of other comic book movies and
team-up movies that we've had so that's
a great idea they started with this
great concept and then they ruined it by
bringing in this leg you know menace
that these these guys are outmatched to
face it's another like magical sky beam
for the hundred thousandth time and it
would be much more interesting to throw
this Suicide Squad that they've already
assembled into some sort of more
street-level defender style situation I
know they're tomorrow but just for the
sake of comparison that where it's like
a group or a clan that had certain
abilities that was armed in a certain
way that we could actually understand
here's how the Suicide Squad is gonna
take on this threat and fight them and
beat them down enough on a much more
street level realizable way it would
make this series much more interesting
in terms of editing I think it's a
little bit garbage in garbage out that
the movie was not good if the raw
materials were not good you can clean it
up and editing all you like you can put
better needle drops there was a lot it
was a very messy movie you could
certainly clean it up but I don't think
that's gonna fix a bad movie that was
unsatisfying and turned it into a good
satisfying movie I think you have to go
back to a more core level than that as
for bringing on one villain I mean the
first two acai squad basically had one
villain it was the Enchantress she was
the villain like there were some side
plots going on but that was basically it
the Joker
in at the very end but almost again more
is a sort of twist ending I don't think
that was the problem with the first
movie and I think we've got a lot of
really good comic-book movies they do
have multiple villains so I think that
the clear answer is a supernatural
threat removing that from the from the
whole thing would make the movie a lot
better bam thank you on that is round
one there we go Dan Merle what's going
on factually here I have a fact
compliment to be paid to Erica because
she avoided one of my particularly
because this is around Halloween yeah
one of my Halloween pet peeves she
referred to Suicide Squad as
Frankenstein's monster I was watching I
watched Halloween wars on the Food
Network they make Halloween cakes don't
judge me and they kept talking about
Frankenstein they're like make make
something of Frankenstein and zombies
and like it's Frankenstein's monster
monster we we should remember that
Victor Frankenstein was the true monster
of the story that's turn Frankenstein
and one quick correction while there was
some development around Harry Osborn
becoming the Hobgoblin or the new goblin
in the next movie dr. octopus was the
one main antagonist in that film much as
Green Goblin was the main antagonist in
the first one so I think it would be
safe to say that that he really only
fought one villain in spider-man 2 yeah
and they developed villains for the next
film in that movie so yeah I mean
spider-man 3 or the amazing spider-man 2
like yeah false advertising on Rhino so
this was this first round was a great
slugfest you were I mean it was non-stop
and you guys were trading blows like
crazy at the end of the day I mean I
love koi with this with a singular
villain argument and I love what LAN was
saying that made sense to me I felt like
you guys kept knocking each other out
and
one that came in and just like dropped
the hammer I thought was Erica because
yes he's going to be writing and
directing it and there are so many
elements but just cohesive film that
that has just like okay I can follow
this linearly I get it I am locked in to
me that's like I saw arguments for and
against both of yours I would love a
street level or if they sold us um if
they saw us if they sold us something
cool and mystical I'd get on board for
that too but it has to make sense and be
a linear film at the end of the day
through the noise came Erica Ishii I go
to Erica Dan I agree this is very
difficult for me to decide who was gonna
get the point and I had to go into
everyone's arguments counter-arguments I
feel like the one that spoke to me III
was going this way and then one actually
had a good closing argument about the
Enchantress and how they already had a
central villain and that the movie stole
you know was not very strong in a lot of
people's eyes but even given that I
think that the way that coy described
his argument wasn't just that there's
one central villain but that is a hero
yes that that dynamic is what would more
firmly establish the tone of the team
and what their goal is I found one and
Erica's are going to be very compelling
but that was for me the best pitch and
the strongest thing that swayed me over
almost taken out I think there's a
really good closing by lon but I still
think that coy for me took it so I'm
gonna go with coy BAM so it's one for
Erica one for coy Danielle can you
settle this for us all right well we
have 47% no supernatural at sounds like
an indictment of the show
29% we have one villain and then at 23%
we have better editing alright so that
means right out of the gate we got a
three-way tie
yeah so we're good this is tough like
unprecedented oh oh and the tiebreak is
established it's a tie instead it's
Danielle's opinion yes all right I'm
listening to the arguments all of them
were fantastic arguments I have to say
that the one that I thought was the most
compelling and well thought out was
Lanza all right lon you take the point
Wow that was unexpected damn no
supernatural and I want to say we had
some great suggestions in both the chat
and on Twitter yes I'm at sleeping
shrimp love that name on Twitter said
did everybody scream dave bautista and
as bane already back in but yeah yeah I
would be that people also heard him
bandied about a solomon grundy perhaps
alright moving on to question number two
lawn is in the lead one-nil to nil
all right question to the screenwriter
for the in development Craven movie said
he may have a face-to-face with Spidey
face-to-face battle I think face me or
Adam yeah yeah oh yeah like a sit-down
like these like I can heat with Pacino
and did you know a square off a battle
with Spidey who should play Kraven the
hunter who should play Kraven the hunter
and it's question number 2 so we start
with player number 2 Ericka Ishii my
pick is Pedro Pascal I feel that we were
robbed with not having him as Doctor
Strange but I think that he needs to
join what is essentially the MCU and is
definitely going to be the MCU he was a
fan favorite for a game of Thrones he's
an incredible performer and actor he's
extremely sexy and he can buff up to be
Kraven i I really would like him to be
part of the mm see you and extended MCU
because let's be real here anything
that's gonna be in spider-man film is
gonna end up in the MCU
and I think this is a really good role
for him plus diversity great Thank You
Erica lon so I read I was reading up a
bit about Kraven and particularly the
last hunt which is a storyline they said
it probably is going to be somewhat
influential to this film it includes a
scene where Kraven the hunter drinks
from a bowl of hallucinogens and then
covers himself in spiders to prepare
eventually he frees himself and starts
killing and eating the spiders who else
do you want to see play out that
sequence then Michael Shannon this is
the part michael shannon was born to
play
also think about Michael Shannon's
intensity when he's
simply hunting we saw him do it in shape
of water we saw him do it in nocturnal
animals you don't want to be in this
guy's crosshairs when he's on the hunt
when he's determined to hunt you down
that's terrifying that's my pick for
craving that all right Michael Shannon
that was a great picture of Hanna
by the way background a koi I am a huge
fan of crayons last hunt of proving
himself and of the actor that I think is
the one and only choice to play him and
that is of course Benicio del Toro this
is a man made to play savagery and
eloquence this is a man played to play
beasts and refined gentlemen alike this
is a man who is so enigmatic you can't
quite put him anywhere
much like craven craven has a legacy and
that he's a family man but also a men he
hunts people the duality of Kraven is
not shined upon enough and I think that
no other man could both be seen drinking
hallucinogens eating through spiders but
also be seen at the Craven off family
dinner the most important thing about
Kraven beyond the hunt aspect is that
these Craven offs keep coming out after
spider-man and there's this long legacy
the reason Kraven kills himself at the
end of Cravens last hunt is because he
feels like he's betrayed his family by
not doing it sooner and now that he's
accomplished this task there's no
greater hunt and he isn't accomplished
it for his family's name
I can see Benicio del Toro as someone
that would believe that strongly and
something I can believe he'd be
something that can hunt someone at the
same time and I see Benicio del Toro as
this character in Sicario as a wolf that
does what needs to be done to accomplish
his tasks no one's more animalistic no
one's more refined no one's more perfect
finish el del Toro yeah fight it out
guys I could not dispute how any of
these men we would not be suited for the
role honestly they are fantastic
performers and I could imagine any of
them taking hallucinogens and eating
spiders
Benicio del Toro as we said and you
agreed that pretty much anybody that
ends up in the Spidey verse is gonna end
up in the MCU and Benicio del Toro is
already in the MCU as the collector
they're trying to keep us up with venom
and creations you mentioned Sicario
which i think is a great example Benicio
there's always so many layers to what's
going on he's so complex you said
mysterious I couldn't agree more
that's what you get with Benicio it's
it's Nikki's never doing anything and
he's single-minded fixated he's doing
things but he's also thinking about the
consequences of what he's doing he's
playing Jesse's he's thinking five moves
ahead that's what we see the
intelligence behind his eyes that's what
you get from DC of the Tor performance
but Craven is just single-minded
obsessive is like I'm gonna kill
spider-man he's a hunter I don't
necessarily see that the other thing is
we've seen Benicio take these parts in
these big comic book these big franchise
movies plays on like we see him show up
and he's always pulled back in these
movies he doesn't get engaged with these
worlds like he does the best roles like
Sicario like usual suspects the phones
that we love him in he shows up in these
movies he gets his paycheck to play
deejay in the Star Wars movies and then
he's off to the next thing
he doesn't sink his teeth into these
roles like like these actors who like
Michael Shannon who shows up Assad and
shows up every scene that he's in he's a
hundred and ten percent you have Michael
Shannon at his full powers in that
McRaven animalistic you've got Sicario
traffic usual suspects you've got like
savages got wolf an animalistic there's
a lot full their sophisticated eetu them
that military man Michael Shannon does
not I love Michael Shannon I warned him
a table he's a little eteri expert that
hand besides militaristically every time
I see Michael Shannon I see Fahrenheit
451 I see shape of water I see 12 strong
I see a man that has composed I want a
man that's beating
[Music]
that way in freaking for me as it goes
great moment out of the whole sort of
Cravens saga and I think Mikey's high
and low I mean he obviously has played
very sophisticated dressed down like you
know like cultured characters confidence
but he also plays crazy people I mean
there was like take shelter race running
around think of the population and that
wasn't a role that he like works the
meta game of looking at the studio
system we all know how this works
they're not gonna they're not gonna cast
him in the m's then in this other
franchise when he's been so prominent in
the DCU that hasn't happened yet people
who go into both you know like Wiggins
Chris Evans well you say so since the
last huge one not cast people in one
franchise cuz they're in the other I
mean they do the Green Lantern and now
he's dead pool but my biggest thing with
both of these are both very refined and
I don't see the other side of the
manifest scale of only seen in Game of
Thrones I don't see enough of his
versatility to play the two sides of
Craven I like Petra Prescott a lot and
I'm under rather seen them as dr.
strange but dr. strange and Craven
couldn't be more different characters so
when you say dr. strange I see it when
you say Craven I don't that's a big
popular fan casting when you say Michael
Shannon I love him as something else but
he's too militaristic for the animal
that his crib and he's got a line around
his shoulders he's hunting make it
through the jungle bunny shell del Toro
might do that at home right now naked
hunting someone wild man mystic mild man
like wearing a 451 is very perform
because it's about this dictatorship
receptors can send a Russian aristocrat
who alleys is exactly what we're talking
about show del Toro he's an animal but
he's also refine that way as well as
many centers were played an animal like
trap these movies are mentioned Alex
wolf he's a literally notice very manly
man he's willing to do anything to
achieve his goals but he's not
animalistic and all he's completely
composed that's the whole point when you
get to the end and like one realizes oh
my god this guy is horrible he's a
killer she didn't realize it the whole
movie because he's so friendly composed
I can't think of a movie in which we
have seen be pleased that duality and I
think she's going on these that does and
you just described his focus as being
the thing you want and then balance I'm
saying the focus of being able to be in
a rage obsessed fixated animalistic
bound to show that side that's composed
but he doesn't really play like rabid
and like maybe if you go back to like
his when he's a thug in a Bond movie in
the a calm and centered and try alright
let's go some final thoughts here Erica
so I these are all these are all very
fine actors but we do have to play the
meta game of who is attached to big
franchises
Frenchy's that could possibly cross over
with Kraven and Pedro Pascal is the only
one who is franchise free at the moment
we do need to see him in this film you
do see that duality of him like just
completely losing and being fixated and
and obsessed to the point where it is
his downfall in Game of Thrones so he is
also a very popular fan cast which is
not a bad thing and they it would be
good to have have the people's voice
heard for some of these castings once in
a while paid Rebecca Pascal thank you
one thing like if Josh Brolin could be
Thanos in case
in the same summer I don't see why
Michael Shannon couldn't be craving
unter in Sony spider-verse even though
he was Saad who's long dead in the DC EU
I don't think that would be blocking him
from taking the job as far as the other
two I mean blood Peniel tutorial a
fantastic actor popped up in a lot of
movies I love always great reliable
could play this part for sure but I
don't really see the wildman' Craven
like somebody who'd be terrifying coming
after spider-man he's too cool he's too
methodical that's just that's just who
Benicio del Toro plays that's who he is
as for Pedro Pascal another great actor
he's I don't know if he's enough of a
draw to Center this movie like he was in
narco season 3 which nobody really
watched you know he's he's a he's a TV
actor who's been a bit player in some
movies he's great I don't know if he's
the guy you put center stage he's also
so swab he's such a ladies ladies
they're so physical exactly who's
playing in Game of Thrones that's sort
of how I see him I don't necessarily
like I think the Russian aristocrat part
great though like running through the
jungle running through the city shirt
ripping off wearing animal pelts going
after spider and I don't know if I
necessarily see Michael Shannon has
played both completely wild lunatics
going crazy in hotel rooms and he has
played very reliable trusty
buttoned-down expert military men he can
play both he's a terrific actor he's
been in these kind of project before and
Briggs a hundred percent I think he
would totally nail this thanks lon coin
so I definitely don't lean into the
business side of this because we've seen
the Deadpool's the Chris Evans the
Thanos is a great example we've seen
that so that doesn't affect my eye I
think of who's best
and for me Pedro Pascal even if there is
no contract issues for me he's very
composed and single-minded and I can't
see him being ravenous and in the jungle
and I haven't seen enough of his work to
trust him with this important character
because if Kraven has done wrong he's a
bad villain if Kraven is written wrong
he's not handled well and I could see
Pedro Pascal without my expenditures
work being too hammy or leaning in the
wrong way Michael Shannon I love dearly
Michael Shannon's all my favourite
actors I wanted him to be cable I think
the moment when you lose your mind
there's two ways to go there's animal
and there's military and we have seen
him when he loses it he's unhinged he
goes military that's what shaping water
was about that is what Fahrenheit 451 is
about I loved Michael Shannon losing his
[ __ ] but he always like that that
cheerleader video where he read the
thing of Funny or Die he always has that
Terry aspect to the way he does things
that would work for Craven when I look
at Benicio del Toro I see an animal on
hinge there's a reason he was cast as a
wolf man there's a reason he gets cast
in these roles where he just seems
untethered and he can also play the
composed in ural suspects while also
playing the animalistic and wolf man the
only one of these actors that when he
loses his mind as he seemed like an
animal I want the aristocrat and I want
the Kraven the hunter and I think the
only one has been use shale del Toro and
he's a draw on top of all that koi thank
you
there you go BAM that is round two dan
would you chime in with some facts and
roll it into your thoughts on the round
sure I mean fact wise I think I could go
back and you know there was a discussion
of what who's been what franchise and
you know there have been actors pulled
from any number of comic franchises to
other comic printers there's so many at
this point it's it's it's inevitable
other than the the accurate observation
made the deputy soda tour is currently
an MCU character is this part of the MCU
who knows Sony it's a half nobody knows
at this point so rolling into my
thoughts I feel like this whole thing
became a Benicio del Toro versus Michael
Shannon debate and you're blond and and
coy both I think gave a lot of good
points about why the other one would not
be good and but there was a third option
there and I feel like nobody ever really
addressed it I thought Erika made some
good points for Pedro Pascal and and you
know you guys both addressed it a little
bit in your closing but I feel like you
both got so caught up in each other's
choices that you didn't think about
Erika's choice and I thought she made a
very good case for it so I would go with
Erika and I'd go with Pedro Pascal all
right so that is one for Erica yeah it
became a real slugfest between Shannon
and Pascal who Ari Shannon and del Toro
who could freak out enormous
Spyder yeah I do
your guys never freaked out in a movie
yes he has man I feel like you know I I
liked where Eric was coming from but I
feel like we got so caught up in these
two that it kind of took over and we
heard just a little bit less about Pedro
Pascal than I would have liked yeah hmm
at the end of the day in these two in
this the slugfest that for better for
worse I felt like dominated that round I
felt like joy took it for me right there
even though I think both ultimately
capable but yeah I got to go with coy so
it's one for Erica one for coy Danielle
settle the score all right what do we
got we've got with 41% Pedro Pascal 37%
Michael Shannon and 21% Benicio del Toro
some really interesting other
suggestions yes um I will say right now
the movie fights live hashtag I don't
think I've ever seen as many thirsty
gifts if you're looking for some first
gifts that's that's where you can find
them handsome round chat was real big on
Nick Cage and Jeffrey Dean Morgan
[Applause]
Danielle Twitter was really big on Joe
Manganiello yeah I'm a big leftovers
head leftover season two one of the best
seasons you know I'd give him a shot you
know I'd let him in the room to audition
the dorky director from Mulholland Drive
and then Craven under that's range
impressive he showed some range in
leftovers he was he's a little bit
unhinged they're also just uh back to
what you guys are talking about in the
MCU and the DCU Laurence Fishburne
straddle does right just recently yeah
okay so it is one for law and one for
Erica coy looking to get on the board
round number three okay opening this
weekend is the Neil Armstrong historical
space drama first man we asked what's
the best biopic of the 21st century
best biopic or biopic if you will no no
of the 21st century question three start
with player three lon some thumb with
Martin Scorsese is wolf of Wall Street
and the reason that this one appealed to
me is it is not just a great biopic it
is it does a great job of telling you
who Jordan Belfort was why he's notable
why he was important what this story was
about him but it is also such an amazing
portrait of our time this current era
and so much else of what's happening
around his individual story there really
comes to stand for so much more than
just the one story of this greedy man
and sort of what became of his company
and that's why I think the movie so
powerful it also works on so many
there's so many layers to it it's
working on so many different levels at
once it is this it is this drama it is
this biopic it is this insightful story
about this one man's life with
incredible performance one day I think
Leonardo DiCaprio's all-time greatest
performances and all these guys that
were sort of around but it's just a
compelling version of that story it's
also a very funny comedy I think it
works completely as sort of a send up a
sort of satire of greed and of the you
know these kind of brokers and this
whole the sort of financial system is it
existed at that time and I think it also
works on a level as a sort of social
commentary sort of about the financial
system it's about the financial crisis
it's about who these people are and why
they work their way and why America
allows this to continually go on and to
keep happening over and over again in
our history so that's a lot to happen
it's got a million moving parts all at
once it's an incredible organizational
job Scorsese doing the five story and
it's also just incredibly compelling
movie it's really long and it's just
super entertaining and fun to watch and
that's I think why it sticks with you
and that's why I picked before Wall
Street
thanks long background a Koi I saw 21st
century biopic and I thought I'm the one
that was not just indicative of the time
but the only one that I think was
prophetic I think the only movie I've
seen in a long time that made me go oh
this is jarring and then when I
rewatched and went oh good god what have
we become and then rewashed it recently
went oh this predicted the downfall of
society was social network when I watch
the social network it's a horror film it
is the only biopic I know that paints
its villain as the hero and then villain
and then hero and the villain you never
really loved the character but you're
still invested in the character at the
end of the day both of our films have a
unlikable narrator and an unlikable
protagonist and both are indicative of
the time and both live in the now but
one of them does it with David Fincher's
malicious and cynical eye in a way that
doesn't feel exhausting but in a way
that makes you optimistic for hope and
go like well when this is over maybe
things will get better while still being
so damn dark and it's really hard to
land the movie that doesn't feel
exhausting while being so negative
because the social network is a
commentary and not just the time it was
made but of now it is a movie that look
back on the most important technological
advance of all time next to the
telephone Facebook has reshaped what
society is and it's about the person
that did that while painting him as a
villain while making you interested in
his next move at no point do you really
root for just knives if actually ask you
Eisenberg but at no point you really
root against him and there are points in
wolf of wallstreet where you're not on
board but I feel like the movie The
Social Network is such a piece of our
time that when we look back on the 21st
century it's gonna be not just the best
biopic it's gonna be the movie that
explains what the hell the 21st century
was thank you coy Erica I chose the
movie hidden figures like its name the
subjects of this biopic we're hidden
Katherine Johnson
Dorothy Vaughan Mary Jackson these are
names that you haven't heard before this
film mostly but there are names that are
incredibly important and these stories
that are untold are unique and they
they're stories that need to be told
especially now this moved this is a
movie that was pro-science in a time
that we really need to hear that message
you know for the for a lot of welcome to
the argument but this is what I want the
21st century to be this is how I see the
21st century is looking towards a
brighter future where people of all
creeds can work together to to further
humanity this is what we need to see in
the 21st century and I'm so glad that
this story is finally being told it
should have been told in the last
century but now we're finally getting
this story and hopefully many others
like it fight it out y'all all right I
would like to say first that this is
exactly what we need in the 21st century
our stories about privilege sociopathic
men that make their fortune and become
famous on the backs of others which
movie am I talking about out of the two
of yours it's the most optimistic biopic
we need it's an actual I think made a
great case for a most inspirational or
important biopic of the 21st century and
I think it's important for this movie to
exist to educate people great I totally
agree with that but it's the best movie
that you say it has a good reason to
exist a lots of movies have a good
reason to existed films and isn't an
argument for why is the best that's an
idea for why people should see it which
I agree but um I think the the other
thing is I'm a little confused I think
your your opening statement was a little
bit at cross-purposes because on one
point you're saying this is the movie
that prophetically showed the dark path
that we were on but then you're like but
it ends hopefully with this note of pop
promise for the future like well how
could it have foreseen the dark path we
were on since 2010 if it ends hopefully
like the things that have happened on
Facebook from 2010 to 2018 are not
hopeful and I think this goes back to
the larger point that I'm making that I
think we're kind of saying the same
thing which is a movie that's harshly
critical of this idea about Wall Street
is about it's about why is America a
place that celebrates sociopathic well I
I don't think that either of your films
really criticize or go far enough
because when you put a protagonist in
like in the limelight who who is really
they're awful people they are awful
people and you put them in the lead role
you ask the audience to relate to them
and I'm done having to relate to these
people getting dumped and Jesse spins
the movie suffering and losing all of
his friends that's not painted in a good
light the whole movie he's losing money
it shows that money isn't important
thing he's not Kraven the hunter like
obviously we accept it like you can have
a venom you can have a movie where we're
not dissing don't because the characters
the main character doesn't mean like the
movie is saying they're a good person
relate to them it is painting them in
human life they are really very
relatable people and you shouldn't be
relating Jordans not a relatable I want
to know their point of view I don't
think it's valuable insight into the
21st century would not be gleaned if we
didn't have this cautionary tale the
cautionary tale of social network is
what we became the movie is literally
like don't do this and then we all did
that's fascinating because David Fincher
saw we're becoming now it happened
I think that's happening at the margins
of the social network a lot of social
network is just about here's the story
of this company about these guys
fighting each other for control of this
company it is an interesting story but
that's a lot of searching there's a
little bit of the social commentary wolf
of Wall Street is 100% about like here
are horrible people behaving in horrible
ways doing you know it's about excess
it's an excessive movie that's about
this excess but in looking at it it's
like why is this allowed why here's
nothing got away with it I just want to
give a little direction here we're
talking about the quality of these
people are they a bad person oh I want
to hear more about why your film right
is the best biopic why your film is the
best work in writing mine has brilliant
directing by David Fincher the score is
incredible one of the best scores of all
time Project X with Scorsese directing
isn't that insightful and it's just
three hours of over bloated times that
movie could have been 2 hours if it had
an editor handling I would have enjoyed
two hours in it and having figures is a
really good movie to card into fifth
grade on a TV I enjoyed it but it's a
very important biopic and it needed to
be told but it's not something I sit
back and watch and go oh this is what I
need right now I'm talking about the
quality of the film it's not the quality
that I hold these two up to wolf of
wallstreet was edited by the same person
who edited Goodfellas and Casino Raging
Bull and now it's bloated I mean sure
she's roll this into your final why I
mean to respond to that I called him an
excessive movie about excess and that's
that's part of it part of the disgust
that you feel by the end of Law from
Wall Street and that is what it's
designed to elicit in you is that you've
spent so much time with these characters
you're sick of them you dislike them
inherently more than you would if you
show a scene or two of these guys it
makes it seem fun and alluring like
Glengarry Glen Ross which is really
about how those people are horrible
desperate pathetic people but because
everybody rewatch is the Alec Baldwin
monologue over and over it seems cool
outside of context that seems cool
there's a movie called boiler room that
does a great job of analyzing how that
seemed out of context looks cool and
misleads these young
into joining a very similar to wolf of
wallstreet kind of business but what
Wall Street by spending all that time it
may seem like yes it's a long movie it's
a three hour movie but you kind of have
to to get that idea of how RZA Bowl
these guys are and how obvious what
they're doing is and how nothing is done
to prevent it thank you on your watch
koi I think that only one of these
movies is going to be the time capsule
of the time the Wall Street collapse was
a hell of a thing there's a lot of
movies about it you listed a few great
ones there's only one movie of this
caliber about where we are in society
now there's only movie that handles the
crosshairs of society tech villains and
all these things with such poise only
one movie is as prophetic as this one
was and only one has the combined nature
of Sorkin Fincher and Atticus Ross and
Trent Reznor only one of these movies
was this good with like army hammer in
this Jesse Eisenberg in this it made
careers of so many stars the movie here
you're describing it has these stars
already built into it so you're loving
Leonardo Caprio getting to do that Oscar
performance but you're wanting to win
the Oscar nobody cared about Jesse
Eisenberg Armie Hammer nobody cared
about this story everybody I remember
everybody like oh they're making a
Facebook movie and then it was Miss
movie no one counted on this movie and
then it blew everyone away because the
quality everyone wanted your movie to be
good and everyone that loves biopics
liked your movie because it's one of
those it is a movie about tropes I
didn't need to watch it again
thank you coy Erica I mean talking about
tropes the social network film was like
kind of like stories like the love
stories she warned into that didn't
actually happen in order to create a
cohesive trope of a film but both of
them we're not debating like the quality
of the film's they're all
oscar-nominated I would say that in in
terms of hidden figures like the
performances were so incredible and
honestly handling racism in like 1960's
America without being ham-fisted is
something that this movie pulled off and
which is difficult to do and I honestly
think that it is a story that needed to
be told these are both great stories and
interesting stories but they're the
stories that we have heard time and time
again I think that the most important
kind of stories that we can be telling
in the 21st century are those that were
hidden in figures thanks Erika BAM
as the end of round a way to incorporate
the title
unlike the suicides Dan Moreau what's
going on with the facts I mean the facts
show this is mostly opinion based so
facts were pretty solid nothing really
factual is worried are you solid figures
on that one so yeah there's really just
about the arguments for me cool um yeah
why'd you roll it into your thoughts
there again while I do not endorse the
shade throwing it the legendary editors
Thelma Schoonmaker who is incredible
it was between for me coy and Erica I
think everyone made a great case and
this was really a very tough call for me
if I'm being honest because I thought
that coin Erica both approached this
question from different angles and I
really appreciated both of those angles
and so it came down to me of like what
most fully answered the question and
while I do 100% agree that I don't like
unquestionably I think hidden figures
probably tells the most important story
I think looking at the overall film and
the arguments made for the film in total
coy swayed me more so I'm gonna have to
give the point to Chloe but I thought it
was a well argue round although yeah I
thought it was really well argued and I
thought all three made strong arguments
I wasn't though swayed by what Erica was
saying about not wanting to watch a
story about these people because I mean
I don't know this might be my personal
opinion coming in I don't know but like
I think art or a film just has to be a
Vaca TIFF it's gonna be about a bad
person's gonna be about a good person
that doesn't make it less like
compelling you know even though yours is
about the best
I don't think that makes it more of a
movie because it's about good people who
did good for society shocking this ago
people would not have thought your guy
was as bad as Mike no right right right
but so taking that out of it because
like that just did not have an effect on
me although so much of what you said did
and you brought up really important
points Erica about the impact of your
film and stories like that that need to
be told I agree with that but I read an
I got to go coy on this one
Danielle what does the internet have to
say on the internet says with 47% the
social network 28% for hidden figures
and then 23% for the wolf of Wall Street
there were some other interesting
obviously everyone no one knows how to
pronounce biopic biopic none of you know
so we have Moneyball was one that
Twitter was really into catch me if you
can not a lot of people who were really
into it a couple of people brought up
some really good really good bio pics
that were made last century someone
mentioned the weight shifts a great
movie but it happened
that's not nice early nineties yeah
totally yeah and no one ray I thought
for sure yeah the social network and
wolf of Wall Street are two films that I
feel like got robbed for oh kademan
or so but I think what Erica was saying
really cut against wolf of Wall Street
which is he's gross like yes he's a
terrible guy and I think people are just
like I don't want to see or support a
movie about it terrible what were you
guys second choices I think it was like
I was like I know this is last century
but on the day all right so you guys
this is a great moment of sport and
sports it's a tiebreaker whoa we're all
tied up at 1 1 1 so here we go this
works just like the speed round I'm
gonna put the tiebreaker out there and
then chime in with your answers and then
the first person who answers will get 20
second will go around in the descending
order that you answered in with 20
seconds each then just like in a speed
round will get those ten second
rebuttals those sweet and second okay
here is your tiebreaker I'm gonna take
Percival out for the tiebreaker it was
announced that Rookie of the Year is
being remade and we working of the year
besides the Sandlot what's the best kids
sports movie hmm
Bad News Bears Bad News Bears
I'll go The Mighty Ducks I was on that
fence Mighty Ducks koi does a miracle
count no those are grown men okay mom is
like is it a sport question okay so if
we will go in this order
Erica lon then coy and then we'll go
back around for 10 second rebuttals my
man Dan Merle is on the clock
Erica begin when the time begins
whenever you speak the bad news bears
the little scrappy sports movie that
kind of started all little scrappy
sports movies for kids it has the trope
like the coach and need of redemption
the scrappy bunch of misfits
it's even got a girl in it which is
really cool it says it has the montage
with the with the music and I'm Mighty
Ducks an iconic beloved movie a lots of
nostalgia a movie that's so well
remembered and liked it actually has a
real sports team that got named after it
no other movie on the at this table
being discussed can say that just a
blood job because they did a great
performance from Emilio Estevez it's
often overlooked in this kind of movie
but he does a great job sort of holding
it all together this thing come time koi
cruddy he's about more than just sports
it's about becoming a better person and
I love that it's such a focused
narrative that it actually spawned a
remake now so the nostalgia is there
both of these movies plot us about
actually focusing it's about more than
just tropes it's about actually becoming
a better human being and mr. Miyagi is
such an important figure to sport and
real life and false narrative and it's
just held up so much that like I said
the sequel is still as good as the
original
plus it is about the alright 10 seconds
do you ever come oh good so the battery
serves as I said was the progenitor and
off of it all I feel that it did it the
most eloquently and with least
problematic elements attached - I prefer
the cartoon bad news bears definitely
the most problematic movie that's been
discussed fullest we're not really
appropriate for a contemporary gets
really out of date now if you go back
and check it and Karate Kid more about
Daniel more about his leg more about
coming-of-age i'm koi 10 seconds that's
the strength of it it's coming of age
and about sport yours is about just
tropes yours about justice tell Jo won't
you describe those movies that are good
all you describe does the fact that
people used to like it mine is about
coming-of-age and sport film about being
a better person and it sells up time
alright Wow three three strong choices
so we will pick the one who does not
move on the one who does not move on
Danielle Radford tell us doesn't move on
[Laughter]
all three great speed round by the way
all three of these really really good
arguments I would have to say that the
one that I connected with the least I
thought had the the least good argument
was coy with the Karate Kid boom that
that's one for coy I'll jump in and say
Eric I felt like your tone on the first
round was a little bit like you were it
almost felt like you were listing
cliches or something that the film has
almost like you weren't trying to sell
Bad News Bears
but you were almost trying to defame Bad
News Bears with like it's got the code
it's got this so I don't know it
could've started it I'm saying they
started like any other film
that it's because of bad news bear is
that it was just bad news there's is so
good at establishing them so yeah for me
it was Erica thank Dan I for me actually
of Danielle and I are on the opposite
side I would advance Chloe because I
thought Chloe made the strongest
argument for why it was not just a good
sports film but a good film in general
so it's between lawn and Erica for me is
too far as who to advance and I do have
to say that lawn had the best counter
argument which is that bad news Pierce
does have a lot of stuff that does not
have not great for kids now plus I kind
of felt the same way to how the first
round was a lot more just sighted saying
the things that were in it and the other
two I felt were some agreements about
why the films were better so I would
also advance Juan and koi fortunately
and I would not advance Erica all right
Erica you came to fight today and you
damn well did you did awesome you took
it to the brink
thank you so much
it's a delightful to children no
absolutely and I would have to come to
you for some opinions during the speed
round weigh-in you see fit
thank you so much more girls in stem so
all right here we go
lawn Harris versus poisoned row boy bad
times at the El Royale opens in theaters
this weekend what's chris hemsworth best
non MCU performance ghostbusters hmm
rush all right we have ghostbusters we
have the racing epic rush lon you spoke
first 25 seconds begin when you speak
now ghostbusters not a beloved
reimagining of the classic comedy but I
think everybody agreed even the people
who didn't like it that Chris Hemsworth
was doing this great inventive comic
turn a really unexpected turn for him
and a role that isn't really this big
showy comic role any punches so brainy
original this was a movie but it's a
very different kind of character and it
showed that kind of range and debris
that kind of energy to it and to stand
among all those other great to me Time
Rush completely arrests in the
performance of two men both of those men
handled each other impeccably this is a
movie about racing directed by Ron
Howard it wasn't just Oscar man it
actually earned all the accolades got it
was under scene but the whole movie is
about one man trying to defend his honor
and he does it in a way that feels
almost samurai ass but it's about racing
plus he's not playing a cliche he's
playing a very nuanced role and that's
something that is the opposite of Thor
it was most range I think
physical comedy gets sort of
underappreciated a lot Ghostbusters who
a movie that was filled with physical
comedy not all of the great Chris
Hemsworth really nailed it he's a very
accomplished slapstick performer that's
not always easy to do and he did it he
nailed
how much we played a token cliche in
ghostbusters for as he played a
character with nuance and rush he played
a role that was the slapstick comedy but
it only landed because that was the
diversity in the film
it wasn't maximal forms in Russia played
an axial force based off a real person
and landed that based on human time all
right let's go - damn it's weird
sometimes
sitting in here hearing - wet you know
there's always sometimes there's there's
a there's a fastball or curveball in one
of these but with this particular one I
heard these students like well these are
the two I think I think coy won me over
on this one so I'm gonna go with coy all
right that's one for coy with rush
Danielle rad Ford um yeah this dude
these are both again really really good
arguments wow this is a great show turns
out the show ends up being really really
really fantastic but I I have to say I'm
going with lon um I did agree that it
was a way for him to [ __ ] for Hemsworth
to show some range and that he nailed
the physical comedy
um I feel like I have seen him do acting
and other things that was something that
you had brought up so gonna go with one
all right so that's uh one one is it
yeah yeah I mean overall never won one
and I felt like I got more specifics
from lon
and yeah for that reason I gotta go
lon so it is 2-1 lon to one going into
question two of the speed round Kurt
Russell's playing a badass Santa in a
new Netflix movie what actor what actor
should play Santa but as a villain Oh
curveball mm-hmm what actor should be
sent as a villain
John Goodman well-tried Cranston I love
these choices all right whenever you're
ready John Goodman doesn't need a lot of
prosthetics or bacon ready to embody our
sort of cultural idea of Santa but he
can also play such loud angry effusive
characters I'm thinking of him it's sort
of stuff like Big Lebowski
Raising Arizona any Coen Brothers movie
so that intensity that loud angry John
Goodman is the frightening miss of John
Goodman plus him already looking like
Santa it's an unbeatable combo 10
Cloverfield Lane John Goodman Santa boy
the duality of this villain is what I'm
resting figure so subverted those
expectations I can picture the rosy
cheeks I can picture the white beard I
can picture the malice in his heart he
is Santa Claus he's a man sneaky in your
house he's a man doing horrible things
he has checked that list twice and he
has found you naughty this is a man who
is doing all of the horrible things that
Walter White doesn't with a good time
rebuttal I mean with Bryan Cranston you
get it's bad Santa he looks like a guy
like a dirtbag who would be playing a
monster he doesn't look like the actual
North Pole twinkle in his eye bowl full
of cherry Santa John Goodman does and I
think just a physic I'm John Goodman's
lost a lot of weight and Bryan Cranston
and plays often wears a fat suit I'm
talking about Hal for Malcolm the middle
meets Walter White I'm talking the
duality of Santa Claus which is the
interesting thing about the movie if you
just have a scary Santa that's a horror
movie I want a movie about nuance on
brain currents I'm oh boy guns blazing
Danielle Radford man I was positive I
was going in one direction and then the
that last minute snipe with the half of
malcolm in the middle' means break in
bed I have to go
I'm at one I agree we got quite a battle
here I'm Erica any thoughts on this one
I mean that round was such fire and just
like bowls arguing for yeah I like love
both men's comedic friendly were like
really sinister were just perfect yeah
no you summed up my thoughts exactly
I would click like and retweet that
round by the way have previously voiced
Santa Claus a good man multiple times so
there you go Dan I'm here for your funds
okay question number three of the
speedrun it is to two we are locked up
what a game the new trailer for glass
just dropped which M night Shyamalan
movie would be improved the most by
including it in the unbreakable universe
or the unbreak of us the happening or
lady in the water
I'll go lady in the water automatic okay
which movie would be best suited in the
unbreakable universe improved by that so
we heard sorry repeat hi I said lady in
the water
yeah you said lady in there happen okay
lon your first for lady in the water
time begins whenever you speak so the
unbreakable versus a universe where
comic book stories and fantasy are sort
of all rooted in reality and lady in the
water is another story where it's all
about elaborate fantasy that has roots
in reality so they already kind of exist
on sort of similar planes plus you could
have cleveland whatever his last name is
heap cleveland paul giamatti for lady in
the water a pretty good character stuck
in and not very satisfy me move them
over get him out of that crummy movie
I'm gonna M night happening by making
the thing that happens to cause the
happening of villain now in the
happening instead of earth going after
you it's a villain that is leading the
earth to revolt against the humanity on
it so it ties into the universe
beautifully by adding a singular twist
which is what enlighten us
and then it makes all the slapstick
acting work because then it's an old 70
style villain attacking humanity doing a
very fantastic fantastic for subplot and
going out and people in the movie it
doesn't really work because we already
know that what's causing the murders of
the deaths in the happening is plants so
I'll let you have like poison ivy is the
bad guy it doesn't really make sense
mind sort of integrates more also what
character from the happening you want to
bring over mark wahlberg who is he
playing i don't remember anything about
him he was a scientist and bringing over
to zooey deschanel it doesn't matter
that that doesn't work as the world
works yes a poison ivy like villain you
exactly said I want mold man I want that
broad in the world I want that ville and
I what I'm attacking using the whole
earth that is a great supervillain plot
from 70s comics it's a silver heat
villain through through a time free boy
go and wind him up and let him go boy
really sold it for me he specifically
incorporated that happening whereas lon
talked about the worlds but I got Chloe
on this one
dan how were you me that question one
more time yes the new trailer for glass
just dropped which M night Shyamalan
movie would be improved the most by
including it in the unbreakable universe
the happening or lady in the water
I think koi made the best answer to that
question he explained the way that
happening has what the hell's going on
yeah so I would also go with koi
excellent so koi takes a three-to-two
lead and I would be remiss if I didn't
ask Dan to do his mark wahlberg and the
happening impression right now what no
thank you
it is game point for coy Chandra right
here lon you need this to keep her going
understood numero Quatro Walmart is
getting into the original content game
by remaking mr. mom they're doing it as
a family-friendly TV show okay what
movie should Walmart remake as a
family-friendly TV show remaking mr. mom
is a family family-friendly TV show what
movie should Walmart remake as a
family-friendly TV show willow small
soldiers willow small soldiers lon well
a beloved movie a great premise a great
world and nothing has ever been done
with it since that original movie is
still very fondly remembered and it
would be really like great to take it
today it would totally fit into the
current prestige TV landscape appeal to
a lot of kids are maybe a little too
young for fantasy as it is on TV right
now like Game of Thrones but have a
great introduction to that genre for
this new you know sort of generation and
it's definitely a world you could keep
playing out over multiple seasons small
soldiers is made for a TV show you can
sell instant toys you've got these two
rival factions you can sell toys at
Walmart it's an instant profitability
plus that world can keep expanding it's
Toy Story but with some slight dark
edges it's also fun because you've got
different worlds you could explore you
could bring in more fantasy I mean plus
you've also got the soldiers Walmart's
very right-wing so it ties into that
world plus it is a movie that does
didn't have the technology which it does
today so now you can use today's
technology with that story time small
soldiers is terrified it was terrifying
when it came out it's still terrifying
it's so violent it's about war toys and
shooting each other and attacking
children it's exactly the wrong message
that a brand wants to spend especially
in 2018 I'm have you been to Walmart
that's kind of their thing plus the idea
of them touching willow is insulting I
don't want anyone to touch willow that
is a classic for a reason Walmart
touching willow would sacrifice the
integrity of the original plus small
soldiers doesn't have that
reverence and so sometime all right
Walmart will take you if you want to
sponsor us Dan yeah I think Oy nailed
every aspect three why why not is
because the coach is not only white what
what what Franco should be made a new TV
show is why Walmart should make it into
a TV show and I think even with Walmart
the one thing that would overwhelm this
is too violent for kids is but we can
sell a shitload of toys so I gotta go
with koi okay that's one for koi
Danielle I have to go with one on this
one because I he got me with its
violence and shooting and attacking
children but earlier his idea of having
something that brings fantasy for kids
that's kid appropriate I thought that
that is something that would fit in very
well with Walmart's kind of messaging so
that's one each you know um I also got a
go lawn on this one yeah we tried to
bring him down because like we don't
touch willow that's not an art let's I
mean yeah when does a when is Hollywood
ever so yeah a lawn just tied this thing
yeah I mean I felt that koi built this
world of what Walmart should create very
well but but in reality they would not
touch something that had to do with
attacking children and children is gun
forty section but they can't they cannot
do it these days and still make money
and Willa would work really well as a
show folks this movie fights is a
classic it is coming down to the very
last question possible evenly matched
fighters all the way here we go
a lot of DC news this week Titans
premieres tomorrow okay so it looks a
transition to the small screen real
quick here Ruby Rose first look as
Batwoman Suicide Squad news so
what suicide squad member should have a
spin-off streaming show on the DC
streaming service suicide squad member
yes is this from the movie or an
assignment from the movie ok Captain
Boomerang we're all in koi katana katana
I love these secrets alright we'll see
you we'll see if she's got your back
from a show is not what we're gonna get
from the Suicide Squad movies so it's a
different it's a change of pace it's
something funny it's something more
hands-on it's something more personal
it's a character study and one more
interesting Suicide Squad character was
presented then captain Berlin he makes
no sense to be in this movie it's
bizarre nothing about him is explained
no back sorry there's nothing but room
to explore in a humorous weekly
half-hour series that kind of just looks
into this guy where its life is 19
katana is the one with back story I want
to hear about the sword I want to hear
about the souls I don't know how she got
her power I want to see a martial art
show that focuses on martial arts this
can fix the void that Iron Fist was and
it can bring new audience to the DC
Universe and it's an actual interesting
character I don't want someone that's a
b-list I don't want someone that's 30
minutes of fluff I want a real character
in that is katana she has so much
potential that hasn't been used fix it
with long form fix it with the show
don't throw in her movie don't waste her
again I mean how does the show even work
she's killing people and then all of
their souls are being trapped in the
sword I don't even get what this movie
would be or who katana is we get so
little information and I think she's
silent did she even say anything in the
spy movie like how's that engine either
I want to learn why she doesn't talk I
also don't care my boomerang because he
is OneNote I don't need to see a guy
drinking all the time I can watch Mel
gifts and that isn't Australian I
probably those are burning around that
characters
- other than that I would rather see
anything command toggles like here -
wonderful time oh all right lovely
really nice cities great wow did you
guys was both sold some really cool
ideas really fun shows but man at the
mmm at the end of the day yeah I got to
go with the katana show so as long as
it's called the katana lon
that was going oh sorry my bad
koi yeah katanas sword of souls Dan I
disagree the only name for the katana
spin-off would be this is katana she's
got my back
streaming decent streaming however even
though coyly did not choose to name it
that I I think his rebuttal was very
strong and if he was in a little bit of
trouble but I think this promoter was
very strong I don't think the
Australians will be that offended I go
okay
and boy you take the game this this was
a journey every question answered we
have no more questions
nicely done
oh yeah you had your own back today
please tell us where we can find you
give some shoutouts say whatever you
like you can find me on Collider heroes
every week also on Marvel movie news
also my Instagram where I review things
I enjoy I reviewed the country of
Ireland recently like my activity shows
I like like a trouble I think the
Internet is about sharing experience and
I think we use it a lot to be critical
but I think that optimism is really
tricky so even if I don't like something
I tend not to talk about it so
everything I put out is quality
happiness because there's plenty of
darkness in the other coordinates so if
you don't like my overall positivity you
won't like my content but if you like
optimism lots of lemonade that's what
I'm about
so if you don't even talk about
something but I didn't like if you were
talking about I loved it awesome thank
you coy and I love your energy and thank
you for being here nicely done man Erica
a she you are also a positive ray of
sunshine but I like you
you're not only positive you have your
you bring the yin and the yang and
everything else right I've got a dark
messed-up Center
but seriously yeah I ten percent agree
with koi he's such a pure sentimental
[ __ ] away but also I'm at Erica Ishii on
Twitter and at the Erica Ishii on
Instagram I also put a lot of happy
nonsense on there and I right now I have
a podcast with Amy Dallen and Travis
McElroy called positivity knee which
about positivity and messages of hope in
ten minutes or less
I think oh it just got a kitten
announced today I'm in maplestory 2 I'm
a voice in maplestory 2 and um I do the
dub of the bleach movie that's on
Netflix right now what is going on in
here so yeah it's out and it's really
fun and find me at geek & sundry right
now the lla by night the vampire the
masquerade show is Fridays at 8 p.m. you
have some time to watch it to binge the
previous episodes before the episode
tomorrow night thank you so much for
having me of course always great to have
you very super cool long I'm not a brave
way of sunshine Wow follow me there it's
pretty negative overall but I appreciate
it anyway dan Morelle where do you stand
on positivity
I love positivity favor of it I just
don't do some positive
my pursue sing skills and abilities I
started as an epic and I'm very proud of
it glad to have you back buddy love you
brother no positivity and just put out a
little positivity there are a lot of
people down in Florida Georgia the
Carolinas and elsewhere that are very
much affected still being affected by
the hurricane Michael and I would just
throw out to select whatever aid
organization you feel you would like to
contribute to and help out a lot of
people because I feel like that is where
we see a lot of positivity and a time
where there's a lot of negativity is
that we can all still get together and
help those that need help
so yeah Red Cross whoever you want to
donate to there's a lot of people that
need help right now so damn good message
thank you sir
Daniel Radford you are I mean - like it
or not you're Reyes on your dress like
Wednesday Addams y'all light up the room
[Applause]
yeah you guys just you can find me all
over the Internet
you can find me at Danielle Radford on
Twitter Danielle underscore Radford on
Instagram I'm with Dan donate some stuff
I've got a bunch of clothes that I'm
gonna try to see if I can send down
because folks need clothes and it can be
especially hard for folks who are
plus-sized to get stuff that they could
wear to work so you know get ready
Florida are you about to get some real
rough thick stuff thanks Danielle yeah
that like that was so nice yeah it was
also kind of really funny the way you
said it
yeah I want to thank you guys for
watching hit me up on on the gram and on
Twitter
when I was at a New York Comic Con this
past week I got to meet some cool people
I want to give a shout out to my friends
Logan Wilson and Ben AF and I also want
to shout out all nations
where my house that and I also want to
shout out Billy biz and jte for holding
it down
thanks for watching everybody
[Applause]
you